here's what would happen if we sent our
trash into the sun
to transport just one year's worth of
our planet's garbage and nuclear waste
to the sun would take
168 million Rockets and the price tag
would be 33 trillion
anyway this may not be a great idea
there are a ton of problems involved in
sending Rockets to the Sun including
missing the Target or a rocket exploding
due to an error on the ground or in the
atmosphere resulting in nuclear fallout
and garbage raining from the sky
regardless this is an expensive plan
that has way too many possibilities for
catastrophic failure it really doesn't
seem worth it maybe instead of looking
for outlandish Solutions we should just
you know stop producing so much waste
because